- Well, it's Thursday.
So, I know about you a little bit.
So what's with the clothes? Why are you...
It's Thursday, it's usually
your Naked Thursdays.
- No, no, this is daytime TV so, you know.
- [Kelly] We're ready.
- Don't ask what I got
underneath these clothes,
because you know, you know,
your Momma will tell you,
"Always have a clean underwear on,
in case something happen to you".
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- On Naked Thursday, I make
sure I have nothing on,
in case something happen to me, see.
(Kelly and J.B. laughs)
- [Kelly] But you have a naked...
- Good thing I call it
Naked Thursday, everybody.
And feel free to partake
in Naked Thursday.
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
Naked Thursday is amazing.
(audience applauds)
It's spreading like wildfire,
everybody's naked on Thursdays now, see.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Naked Thursday's a fabulous night.
(J.B. groans)
We love it, we love it.
And we turn a little musical on.
If you've never danced with
your companion, butt naked,
you have not lived.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- I don't think I've lived.
- [J.B.] Oh, man.
- You've never done that?
(audience applauds)
- I'm talking about some, some...
- I've totally done that.
(audience laughs) I'm talking
about jumping around music.
Everything's shaking,
you know what I mean?
- No, no.
- I love it.
- No, I've done like some
slow, like some Post Malone.
Like he got something slow going on.
- Maybe something with
a little more groove,
a little more groove to it.
(audience laughs)
- I'm just saying, this
is what you should do
for your next birthday.
- I...
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Yeah, we've
just given you homework.
So, your next birthday, you
got to do some naked dancing.
- Around the dinner
table too, we all have.
- [Kelly] Not with your daughter.
This is just for you and your man.
(Kelly laughs)
- [J.B.] Close the curtains too.
- We don't want to freak,
we don't freak her out.
(J.B. laughs) So, I
want to talk about this.
Wait, the new season of
"Curb Your Enthusiasm"
it comes out this month.
- Oh, yeah.
- So tell us about it, what's happening?
- You know, I can't tell you too much,
because I'm gonna tell you what I do.
I am truly, although I'm on the show,
I'm a fan of the show and I'm just,
I'm a big fan of the show
before I got on the show.
So, when I go to work, you know,
now, I'm gonna tell you
what they call Larry.
They call Larry, the Hog.
Because Larry will do scenes with me,
but he won't let me do scenes
with anybody else, on my own.
You know what I mean?
They call him, Richard Lewis
calls Larry, "Larry the Hog".
So, he hogs up J.B.
So, I watched the show like a fan
and a lot of times, I don't even know
who the special guests are or anything.
So, when it comes on,
I sit there like this, I watch the show.
And I don't want to know everything.
I hate knowing everything.
You know, you know how actors are.
Sometimes actors don't
even watch themselves,
because they just,
they feel like they
could've done it better.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah, we're hard on ourselves.
- We change, we change over a few months.
We become better actors.
You know, we'll see
something a year later,
like, "I did that?
Why's my hand like this?
Why am I doing this? Oh, I hate myself".
You know?
- Why do I look like a sloth when I sing?
Yeah, I don't know.
- [J.B.] Right, right, we judge ourselves.
So, I tend to watch the
show and a lot of times,
because the show's improvised,
I don't remember what I said.
So, sometimes on the way home, you know,
my wife would call me on the way home
and she'll say, "How was your day?"
I'll say, "Oh, it was great".
And she'll always say,
"What did Leon say today?"
My character, she's like,
Not, "What did J.B. say?",
"What did Leon say today?"
And I'm like, "Ooh, what
did Leon say today?"
(audience laughs)
- You have no idea.
- It's cool that I just
separate the two characters,
myself and my character I play,
I love telling her what Leon said.
(Kelly laughs)
You know? I like that guy.
(audience laughs)